Tak.
Więc przechodząc dalej, bity
i qubit będą fundamentalną obliczeniową podstawą,
przy pomocy której możemy się zmierzyć
ze złożonymi problemami na świecie.
Spróbujmy więc zrozumieć różnicę między nimi
i skąd bierze się moc qubit.
Jeśli spojrzymy na lewą stronę,
to jest sposób na opisanie — i będziemy używać tych diagramów
przez całą prezentację, żeby
zobrazować tę moc — widzimy okrąg
i dwie kropki. Gdy kropka jest na biegunie północnym,
to jest zero, a gdy jest na biegunie południowym — jedynka.
To są dwa stany klasycznego bitu. Teraz qubit to
jednostka informacji w świecie kwantowym.
I tutaj mamy do czynienia ze sferą —
sferą jako zerem i jedynką.
I możemy mieć je w tym stanie superpozycji.
Mamy do dyspozycji specjalną sztuczkę,
bo nie tylko możemy umieszczać je w różnych pozycjach na tej sferze,
ale wyobraź sobie, że każdy z nich
jest jak mały księżyc,
który jest na tej sferze i możemy go obracać.
Tutaj widzisz, że
dolna sfera została lekko obrócona,
dlatego widać trochę niebieskiego
i różowego. Moglibyśmy obrócić ją całkowicie —
tutaj mamy obrót o sto osiemdziesiąt stopni.
Mamy więc pojęcie fazy, którą kwantowość nam daje.
Kwantowość oferuje nam trzy super moce widoczne w qubit —
to jest moc superpozycji,
moc interferencji
i moc splątania.
Przyjrzyjmy się im. Zasada superpozycji jest właściwie
dość prosta do zrozumienia.
Gwiazda po lewej stronie —
jesteśmy albo na biegunie północnym (zero), albo południowym (jeden).
Jeśli dodamy te dwa stany,
dostajemy qubit w superpozycji, który ma jednocześnie
zero i jedynkę — północ i południe.
Prawy diagram jest taki sam,
ale teraz wykonamy mały trick —
zastosujemy gate, quantum gate.
To, co tutaj zrobiliśmy, to — pamiętasz? —
możemy teraz zmienić, możemy teraz
obracać te małe księżyce, prawda?
Obróciliśmy go o sto
osiemdziesiąt stopni i teraz mamy jedynkę.
Gdy więc dodamy zero plus jeden, otrzymujemy
stan superpozycji,
ale zauważ, że jest inny.
Ten po lewej —
nadal jest zerem i jedynką, ale teraz ze stanem obróconej fazy.
I to okaże się bardzo potężne,
bo pozwoli nam wykorzystać drugą naprawdę ciekawą rzecz, czyli
zasadę interferencji.
To operacja, której nie możemy wykonać w klasycznym
świecie bitów. W tym przykładzie mamy
zero i jedynkę po lewej, plus
ten nowy stan, który stworzyliśmy,
który też jest zerem i jedynką,
ale z tym obróconym księżycem. Gdy to teraz zrobimy,
możemy sprawić, że te dwa stany zainterferują,
i zauważ, że stało się coś naprawdę interesującego —
wyeliminowaliśmy stan jedynki
i zostaliśmy ze stanem zerowym.
Udało nam się to, bo skłóciliśmy ze sobą te stany.
Kolejne pytanie, które teraz mamy,
to ile stanów możemy tworzyć.
Piękna rzecz w kwantowości polega na tym, że możemy tworzyć wykładniczą
liczbę stanów. Spójrzmy na system, który ma
pięć qubit. W tym przypadku przedstawiamy te qubit
jako niezależne qubit — widzisz je po lewej,
zera i jedynki, które się mnożą. Mamy ich pięć,
więc liczba stanów, które możemy stworzyć — na
komputerze kwantowym przedstawionym na sferze po prawej —
to dwa do potęgi
równej liczbie qubit, które mamy. W tym przypadku mamy pięć,
więc dwa do potęgi pięć to trzydzieści dwa stany.
Widzimy więc trzydzieści dwa takie małe księżyce.
Zauważ, że w tym przypadku nie uwzględniliśmy
żadnej fazy — wszystkie są różowe. Potężny aspekt
korzystania z tej właściwości zwanej splątaniem w świecie kwantowym
polega na tym, że możemy teraz tworzyć stany
takie jak ten przedstawiony po prawej,
gdzie mamy te kombinacje różowego
i niebieskiego — i tego stanu nie można opisać
jako niezależnego iloczynu
tych pięciu qubit. W tym przypadku,
skoro mamy trzydzieści dwa stany,
to mówi nam coś naprawdę głębokiego.